I am a huge fan Outkast like changed oh
yeah thanks me so you're gonna
collaborate with andré 3000 again how
come people girl power
a greeting may I have a half-caff decaf
mint mocha latte foam on the bottom
served in a flower basin if y'all got
some green food coloring back there
throw it my brother from another mother
man
and when I say mother you know I'm
talking about art right cuz we got cut
out of her womb what's up man what's up
Andre Andre who I ain't gonna say it man
it's not 2999 it's not to beat no no hey
what happened to you after the show um I
just must decide I snuck out thought
perchance you went missing no no the
voices yeah do what voice ye why you got
a ball Isis man why are you doing the
voice why doing that man one green
half-caff half decaf mint mocha latte
foam on the bottom in a vase I got a new
idea for an album and it's gonna be just
the sound of screeching metal and then
only one spoken word per track cool too
that's more than screeching metal sounds
I talked about earlier man mint mocha
latte foam on the bottom in a vase or
Boz you weren't here not that's your
that's you the only [ __ ] to ever order
that drink yeah okay so what is going on
with me what is happening with that what
the [ __ ] happened man
well you sum up we used to be somebody
man we used to be a team we was on top
then you went and lost your [ __ ] mind
can we just lose this man can we just
lose the 3000 and just have you talk as
andré tell me tell me straight up man
what happened you know I'll be a better
domain if you looked into the pinwheel
with your third eye thought she was
gonna say some stupid [ __ ] like that and
everything will be with my man this big
good man thank you thanks for seniors
okay my man matter of fact I got an
appointment right now to go get fitted
for it you gotta go you leave a me NASA
[Music]
don't do it may eros Artemis and Apollo
dad you through your musical journey you
go what why does your breath smell like
birds see I'll be well thank you café
craftsman you're welcome
[Music]
sorry he didn't actually pay for that I
got it
[Music]
you